the International celebration of
Stoicism Week 2015 begins today for a
philosopher like me who focuses quite a
bit on moral theory and particularly on
ancient philosophy this is a really
important event and I can't thank the
people at the University of Exeter and
the modern stoicism / notice ism today
blog for organizing all of this what I'm
going to do this year is very similar to
what i did last year a series of seven
videos this is the first of which they
have are going to be focused on stoicism
in one way or another and some of them
will be personal much of it will be my
own contribution by way of talking about
stoic authors and this year I'm actually
focusing very much on Cicero so um I
wanted to talk in this first video about
my experience of being enrolled in the
class last year and my short experience
in enrolling in the class this year
because it's just begun and about what
we've got coming up so last year was
really great I am very happy to see
somebody putting together something like
a hand mark just like in ancient times
and producing exercises and then people
getting together whether in you know
events face-to-face or virtually like
this through the internet and
corresponding and talking about this by
the way I'm not even myself a stoic I'm
more like Cicero and somebody who draws
upon stoicism here and there and is a
great appreciation for it but who
doesn't agree with it on every single
point and who mixes in some Aristotelian
azum and some other things as well but
I'm really happy about this I had great
experience last year actually doing the
work involved in the exercises I'm
looking forward to it this year I've
already begun
my wife and I this time arguing it
together although virtually since she's
in California right now so we listen to
the the morning meditation together and
we both read the noon the noon
meditation in the handbook and tonight
we can't do it at the same time but
we're going to listen to the evening
meditation and hopefully text about it
it's very nice to be able to share this
with somebody like that close friend you
know for some people family member you
know spouse's that that sort of thing
really brings it home because stoicism
isn't just about you know sort of an
aloof cold withdrawal from everything
it's about human relationships and how
we can live our human relationships in
more rational and more humane and more
compassionate ways so I'm really looking
forward to what we've got going the
exercise today had to do with thinking
about qualities that we value in our own
life and in the lives of others and most
interestingly whether these had changed
over time I know for myself as a 45 year
old man who has gone through many phases
and stages that they certainly have and
some of that growth and development has
been informed by stoic authors so I'm
looking forward to you know going back
over that all that said now what I'd
like to talk about in this hopefully a
very brief video for day one is what
I've got coming up in the other videos
in this series so four of the videos for
this week beginning tomorrow are going
to be on Cicero's texts and I've picked
for them I'm not going to go very very
deep into them i'm just going to hit on
certain highlights but these are texts
of cicero in which he tells us important
things about early stoicism and what's
called middle stoicism we don't actually
possess any of the texts of middle stuff
at this time or even early stoicism but
who knows maybe they'll uncover some of
them somewhere but we know quite a bit
about their doctrines and their way of
life from people like Cicero who had
stoics as participants in the dialogues
that hero so the works that I am going
to focus on our I'm not sure which order
i'm going to do these and i'm going to
decide this tomorrow on the end which
has to do with the the the you know the
highest good and also the worst evil in
human life I'm duties pretty
self-explanatory but very rich work his
tusculum disputations and on the nature
of the gods the last of which is what we
might call some some theology the Stoics
would have seen that is part of physics
that however and they had particular
views on not only the nature of the
divine but whether the existence of the
divine could actually be proven and how
we could come to understand their place
in it so I'm going to do one video each
talking about some of the key ideas and
some of the interesting facets of those
works we're said that some people were
watching this and participating in stoic
week might not have already you know
encountered and so that you can go back
to it on your own after stoic week is
over of course and read the Cicero
you're certainly going to enjoy it
because he is a great dialogue writer
and he was really brilliant thank you he
doesn't actually get enough credit for
as he put it taking Greek philosophy and
putting it into the Latin tongue so
those will be four things this thursday
in milwaukee i am actually going to be
hosting a stoic week event at the hudson
business lounge of all places i know it
sounds rather strange to be doing stoic
philosophy and business place but it's
actually a collaborative office space
where i will be talking about how some
of the key ideas of Stoicism can lead to
a
or if you're already happy a happier
life and I'm going to video record that
and then that will actually be one of
the videos for the week so you can look
forward to that probably friday or
saturday sunday the last day of the week
day seven I am going to take a composite
of my own video recorded reactions to
the mid time date you know the noontime
meditation which in this case like I
said was about what it is that we value
what qualities we find valuable in
ourselves and others how that has
changed over time so that would be a bit
more personal and I'm going to record it
each day my own reactions to it and i'll
bundle them together in one video at the
very end so I'm very excited about stoic
Week 2015 I've got you know some things
going on here in Milwaukee so if you're
in the area connect up with me happy to
to you know talk about about stoves is
more about philosophy in general check
out the other videos if you're
interested in Cicero or and what my
reactions are or the event if you're not
able to make it and I can't encourage
you highly enough both to participate in
the stoicism week class you'll get a lot
out of it even if you go out through it
before or try it again and to show some
gratitude towards the University of
Exeter modern stoicism people in
particular to dial Robertson for putting
together this this great event you know
we we commemorate so many things that
are rather trivial in life and we don't
have a lot of space for thinking about
you know great thinkers and thoughts
that can transform our lives stoughton
tweak is that sort of thing so everybody
who can get anything out of it should be
involved with